every day the shutdown goes on more
government facilities have to close this
morning that includes the Smithsonian
Institution it's 19 museums and
galleries along with the National Zoo
will be off-limits to visitors until
further notice the world's the largest
collection of museums had stayed open
using money left over from its nearly 1
billion dollar budget last year at
O'Keefe is outside the National Zoo in
Washington Edie good morning are they
still feeding the animals they are still
feeding the animals Michelle but the
gate is locked except for workers bad
news for anyone who was planning to stop
by the zoo staff assures us the roughly
2,700 animals will be cared and fed over
the course of this shutdown but visitors
won't be able to get in until it's over
across the country some national parks
have remained open during the standoff
but are operating with limited staff as
a result visitors are leaving behind
overflowing garbage bins that pose a
threat to wildlife in California adesh
from Joshua Tree National Park some
local business owners are pitching in by
cleaning and restocking bathrooms and
emptying trash bins conservationists
warn if the shutdown continues much
longer visitors could cause permanent
damage to these natural resources now
while the zoo and parks are closed there
are other departments that are also
affected agriculture justice homeland
security Housing and Urban Development
parts of the State Department all closed
but the Pentagon and the VA are
operating as normal in modern times the
longest shutdown ran 16 days back in
2013
if talks at the White House failed to
come up with an agreement today this
shutdown could last far longer Nora
it's hurting a lot of people ad thank
you